Ein Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Es hat sich etwas getan im Bereich Doping im Fußball und auch etwas weitergefasst und darüber möchte ich sprechen mit Jonathan Sachse vom korrektiv.org, der auch die Seite fußballdoping.de betreibt. Jonathan, schön, dass du dich so spontan bereit erklärt hast, mit mir zu sprechen. Hallo. Ich hoffe, die Hörer haben deine Stimme noch im Ohr, denn wir haben ja zusammen auch ein vierstündiges Gespräch zu Fußballdoping aufgenommen. Ein Tribünengespräch ist allerdings auch schon eine Weile her.
Vier Stunden war das. Das war mir gar nicht mehr so eine Erinnerung. Meine Stimme hört sich glaube ich ein bisschen nahe Sahler heute an, falls der eine oder andere mich nicht mehr erkennt. Damals habt ihr mich ja dann scheinbar sehr, sehr lang gehört. Heute kling ich ein bisschen anders.
Ja, aber umso schöner, dass es noch mal geklappt hat, dass wir miteinander sprechen, diesmal im Rahmen eines Kurzpasses. Heute werden es keine vier Stunden, da kann ich dich beruhigen. Und zwar gibt es zwei aktuelle Anlasse dafür. Und für den einen davon bist du selbst verantwortlich zusammen mit deinem Kompagnon Daniel Drepper auch vom Korrektiv und auch involviert auf der Seite fußballdoping.de. Magst du mal kurz mir und den Hörern noch mal erklären und erzählen, was ihr gestern veröffentlicht habt am Dienstag?
Was wir gemacht haben ist, wir beschäftigen uns ja schon länger mit der Doping-Vergangenheit an dem Universitätsklinikum Freiburg. Das hat über Jahrzehnte eine wichtige Rolle gespielt, im westdeutschen Doping-Bereich und auch für den Fußball. Es gab verschiedene Kommissionen, die versucht haben, das so oft zu arbeiten, was eigentlich alles nach Vergangenheit gelaufen ist. Das ist ein relativ kompliziertes Konstrukt, wer da alles an der Aufklärungsarbeit daran beteiligt ist. Einfach zu verstehen, ist, dass nach und nach jetzt Gutachten veröffentlicht werden, wo dann immer zu bestimmten Aspekten die Ergebnisse dieser Kommission veröffentlicht werden. Ein Gutachten, was bald rauskommen soll, aber noch nicht rausgekommen ist, ist über die Verquickung von dem VfB Stuttgart und SC Freiburg mit dem Universitätsklinikum Freiburg, was damals da so gelaufen ist. Das ist das, wo wir vorab mal reinschauen konnten. Eine Version dieses Gutachtens liegt uns vor. Wir haben einfach aufgeschrieben, was die Kernergebnisse dieses Gutachtens sind. Ich versuche es hier mal ganz kurz zusammenzufassen. Das Grundsätzliche werden einige schon kennen, denn es gab vor anderthalb Jahren schon mal so eine Welle. Da ging es auch viel um Doping im Fußball. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir auch irgendwann dann damals gesprochen haben.
Wir hatten kurz danach gesprochen, aber wussten, als wir den Termin ausgemacht hatten, noch nicht, was da passieren würde.
Ja, ja, so war das. Genau. Und was damit schon herausgekommen ist, ist, dass Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er Jahre der VfB Stuttgart und SC Freiburg Anabolika bestellt haben über die Universitätsklinik Freiburg. Und besonders bei einem Arzt, der so als Spritzen-Doktor bezeichnet wird, Armin Klümper, der mittlerweile 81 lebt, lebt in Südafrika, hat sich zurückgezogen und der hat damals einen Status gehabt, wie Müller-Wolf hat jetzt vielleicht so vom Guru haften, nicht von den dopigen Sachen, die mit ihm in Verbindung stehen. Und was wir als Neues in dem Gutachten lesen konnten, waren deutlich mehr Details, wie das damals abgelaufen ist. Ich nenne nur ein Beispiel, wie zum Beispiel der VfB Stuttgart damals in seiner Saison, wo sie Vize-Meister wurden, das war, jetzt muss ich mal nachschauen, im Sommer 1978 zum Trainingslager in den USA gefahren sind und für dieses Trainingslager ein großes Paket Anabolika bestellt haben. Auf eine Abrechnung, die die Gutachter einsehen konnten, sind 600 Tabletten Anabolika drauf, das ist ganz schön viel. Die Gutachter haben auch so eine eigene Rechnung aufgestellt. Nach deren Einschätzung hätten damit 20 Spieler im Trainingslager jeden Tag eine Anabolika-Tablette schlucken können und so gab es verschiedene Abrechnungsstufen und Zeiträume, wo man konkret nachweisen kann, dass zumindest Anabolika bestellt wurde. Ob das wirklich genommen wurde, kann man im Nachhinein nicht mehr ganz genau sagen. Das ist das eine, wo es ein bisschen mehr Details als damals gab. Das andere, was wir noch spannend fanden, war, dass es einen Zeitzeugen gab, der sich bei dem Gutachter gemeldet hat und beschrieben hat, wie das damals ablief in der Klinik, wenn Fußballer interessiert waren, sich zu dopen. Wir beschreiben bei uns mal ein konkretes Gespräch von jemandem, der sich ganz vorsichtig vortastet und sagt, der war früher in meiner Startelf, jetzt wird er nicht mehr aufgestellt. Was gibt es denn noch für sportmedizinische Möglichkeiten? Dann wurde dem Herrn, der ihn empfangen hat, schnell klar, der hat schon ein paar Sachen gemacht. Das Standard-Repertoire ist abgedeckt und der hat sehr konkret danach gefragt, was es darüber hinaus noch für Möglichkeiten gibt. Da ging es auch um Anabolika. Das ist deswegen interessant, weil das ein ganz typisches Gespräch damals war, wie Doping-Gespräche funktioniert haben. Das war ein Aufklärungsgespräch, vielleicht sogar als ein Anti-Doping-Gespräch getarnt. Durch dieses sehr detailliertes Gespräch wusste man danach, aber als Sportler, wie man genau Sachen anwenden kann und welche Wirkungen das hat. Das haben wir versucht, nochmal zu erzählen. Vielleicht noch ein letzter Punkt, den ich jetzt fast vergessen habe. Wir haben uns nochmal den SC Freiburg genau angeschaut, der deswegen interessant ist, weil immer wieder Doping-Bezüge in verschiedenen Jahrzehnten aufgetaucht sind, nicht nur 70er-, 80er-Jahre. Es gab den ersten Doping-Fall in der Bundesliga-Geschichte damals, beim Ersatz-Torwart von Freiburg 1992. Und es gibt vor allen Dingen ein Kapitel, was noch gar nicht so richtig aufgearbeitet ist, weil der SC Freiburg damals als Mannschaftsarzt von 1998 bis 2007, also ziemlich lang, Andreas Schmidt im Team hatte. Andreas Schmidt ist auch von der Universitätsklinik Freiburg und war gleichzeitig damals auch der Arzt im Team Telekom. Deswegen wurde er im Nachhinein auch sehr unpopulär, weil damals genau gezeigt wurde, wie er beim aktiv mitgeholfen hat, das Team Telekom, das Siegratsportmannschaft, um Jan Ulrich zu dopen. Da ist noch eine Menge Aufklärung zu leisten, wie er den SC Freiburg, was er da mit den Spielern angestellt hat. Das war doch länger die Zusammenfassung als gedacht, aber jetzt einmal komplett abgefrischt.
Ja, aber sehr schön. Ich werde ja definitiv auch den Artikel nochmal verlinken. Da empfehle ich allen Hörern, sich das in Ruhe durchzulesen. Ich habe eine Reihe von Fragen, wie du dir vorstellen kannst. Und jetzt fangen wir mal eigentlich von vorne an. Wir sprechen hier von Vorfällen, die Ende der 80er stattgefunden haben. Also jetzt die aktuellen, die ihr jetzt belegen könnt, wo es Belege gibt. Es gab immerhin Bestellungen. Und dann kann man schon zumindest die Meinung vertreten, eine Bestellung hat vermutlich auch zur Einnahme geführt. Als Meinung kann man das, glaube ich, denke ich, so sagen. Da soll sich jeder Hörer ein eigenes Bild machen. Dann habe ich dazu zwei Fragen. Zum einen, warum wird das alles erst jetzt aufgearbeitet? Und hätte man nicht damals dann eventuell schon positive Dopingproben haben müssen?
Genau, also zum ersten, diese Untersuchungskommission oder andersherum. Also was damals passiert ist, warum überhaupt diese Belege existieren, ist, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft in Freiburg damals gegen diesen Arzt Armin Klümper ermittelt hat. Und da ging es aber nicht um Doping, sondern um ein Betrugsverfahren, um darum, dass er einfach seine Sachen falsch abgerechnet hat und davon profitiert hat. Und sie haben sich die Dopingaspekte gar nicht so genau angeschaut, es lagern aber seitdem Akten einfach da, wo Dopingaspekte drin sind. Damals haben sie einen Punkt, stimmten die Beträge und überhaupt. Und jetzt ist es natürlich interessant, zu schauen, was stand eigentlich auf den Beträgen. Und dieser Zugang zu diesen Akten wurde erst dadurch gewährt, dass sozusagen aktiv entschieden wurde, viele Jahrzehnte später, sehr spät. Wir brauchen Untersuchungskommissionen, die aufarbeitet, was damals alles passiert ist. Das wurde auch immer wichtiger, mit denen war mehr klar, wurde auch im westdeutschen Sport viel gedoppt, das war eben nicht nur der DDR-Sport, sodass sozusagen von oberster Stelle entschieden wurde, wir investieren, wir suppressionieren das sozusagen und erlauben auch dieser Kommission Zugänge.
Und wer ist da die oberste Stelle? Also wem untersteht diese Kommission, die jetzt auch dieses Gutachten erstellt hat?
Genau, ich kann ehrlich gesagt gar nicht ganz genau das Organigramm jetzt nachzeichnen im Podcast, aber die müssen erst mal, müssen die Mitglieder an das Universitätsklinikum Freiburg berichten, auf der Webseite wird auch veröffentlicht und die prüfen sozusagen nicht, dürfen keinen inhaltlichen Einfluss nehmen, aber sie prüfen sozusagen noch mehr juristisch so Sachen wie, wenn da jetzt Leute zitiert wurden, wurde das einverständnisvoll eingeholt, haben wir das schwarz auf weiß und so Sachen. Das ist sozusagen die Aufgabe und dann wird das dort relativ unabhängig auch veröffentlicht, was aber in der Vergangenheit passiert ist, das hat man immer so ein bisschen mitbekommen, ist, dass natürlich trotzdem relativ viele Leute da versucht haben mitzureden und Sachen zu verfälschen. Es gab diverse Kommissionen, es ist nicht nur diese eine gewesen, die immer wieder auseinandergebrochen sind wegen Streitigkeiten und es wird wahrscheinlich auch nie einen richtigen Abschlussbericht geben von dieser Kommission. Das ist alles sehr komplex, das Gebilde, weil sie einfach nicht zusammengefunden haben. Da sind viele Interessen, da sind viele Politiker mit dran verstrickt gewesen. Also das ist alles ein Geflecht, was ich jetzt ja in Berlin, von Berlin aus gar nicht ansatzweise so beschreiben kann, wie es abgelaufen ist, das interessiert dann auch keinen mehr.
Aber das heißt, die Uni Freiburg untersucht sich quasi selbst und macht dann aber nochmal, ich würde sagen, den Faktencheck, bevor etwas veröffentlicht wird und allein durch dieses, dass man da nochmal über jedes Zitat geht und so, da versuchen sich viele Leute einzumischen.
Nee, eigentlich, ich würde sagen, glaube ich, noch mehr einen Schritt vorher, in dem auch sozusagen negativ über Gutachter gesprochen wird und da einfach so Streitigkeiten ein bisschen angestichelt werden. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Einfluss sie am Ende wirklich haben, bei dem, was veröffentlicht wird, dass sie da irgendwie ganze Passagen ausstreichen können oder so. Ich kann mir vorstellen, da gibt es auch Möglichkeiten. Da habe ich jetzt aber kein Beispiel, was da genau passiert ist. Also, erstmal geht es denen darum, da juristisch sauber zu sein einfach. Du hattest dann eine zweite Frage gestellt, also genau, Doping-Tests. Jetzt muss ich mal kurz zurückerinnern, also ein Problem ist, dass es damals natürlich nicht in dem Umfang Doping-Tests gab, wie es es jetzt gibt. Jetzt habe ich natürlich die ganzen Zeitreihen nicht mehr vor Augen, aber es gab auf jeden Fall noch keine Trainingskontrollen, wenn ich das richtig, also Trainingskontrollen oder Wettbewerbskontrollen, ich schwanke jetzt gerade, was das erste eingeführt wurde. Aber die Anzahl war viel niedriger und in einem Bereich gab es noch gar keinen Kontrollen. Und ich glaube, es waren die Trainingskontrollen und das wurde noch nicht nach so vielen Sachen getestet. Also vielleicht gab es noch nicht mal einen Anabolikattest damals. Die Analyse war so noch gar nicht möglich. Aber also kurz zusammengefasst, die Trainingsqualität konstigiert hat sich komplett verändert. Sie war damals eigentlich noch gar nicht so vorhanden.
Und aber, damit wir uns richtig verstehen, Anabolikaten standen damals schon auf der Dopingliste und es müsste eigentlich jedem klar gewesen sein, der etwas, ein Anabolikum eingenommen hätte, dass das nicht legal ist, nicht erlaubt ist. Genau, genau, das ist richtig. Ja, ziemlich interessante Erkenntnisse. Wie haben denn die Vereine darauf reagiert? Also ihr habt ja sowohl den VfB Stuttgart als auch den SC Freiburg mit den Ergebnissen eurer Recherchen vertraut gemacht.
Genau, also wir haben, man muss sagen, einen relativ kurzen Frist, vielleicht am Montagmorgen, ich glaube um sieben Konfrontationen verschickt an beide Vereine mit 24 Stunden Frist, also mussten sie innerhalb von 24 Stunden antworten, finden wir aber gerechtfertigt bei so einer großen Pressestelle, wie die Bundesliga-Vereine es haben. Und die Reaktion war beim SC Freiburg, dass sie uns am Abend an den Fragebogen sozusagen beantwortet haben, wobei beantwortet heißt auch, dass sie jetzt mehreren Sachen einfach in die Stellung genommen haben, mit Beschreibnis und Text zum Beispiel, dass sie jetzt auf die konkrete Frage, wurden denn Spieler gedobt, gab es da einfach keine Antwort. Um ein oder andere Sachen haben sie dann nochmal genau bestätigt, ja, Andreas Schmidt war von dann bis dann bei uns beschäftigt, der Arzt. Und was sozusagen beide betont haben, ist, dass sie ihr eigenes Archiv zu Verfügung gestellt haben, nach dieser ersten Welle, die es im letzten Jahr gab zur Berichterstattung. Da hat sozusagen derjenige, der diese Welle ausgelöst hat, ja gut. Ach, da war er gar nicht mehr mit beteiligt. Aber die restliche Kommission, da gab es auch Treffen zwischen den Vereinen und der Kommissionsvorsitzenden, Paoli heißt die Dame. Und das haben sie mir sozusagen ums Ausführliche beschrieben. Gestern hatte ich ein längeres Telefonat mit zwei verschiedenen Pressesprechern des VfB Stuttgart, wo es auch nochmal viel darum ging. Sie haben sozusagen auch eine Person, die mehr dafür beauftragt ist in den ganzen Medien. Aber der Kommunikationsarbeit, dass es selber reingearbeitet hat. Und was ich spannend fand, ist, dass der VfB selbst auch Zugang zu den Akten bekommen hat, um selber diese Belege nochmal überprüfen zu können. Also die Vereine sagen von sich aus jetzt erst mal, sie sind selber daran interessiert, das aufzuklären, was da passiert ist. Die einzige Frage, die ich mir so ein bisschen stelle, es gibt natürlich immer noch Leute in wichtigen Ämtern, besonders beim SC Freiburg, die zu damaligen Zeiten auch schon aktiv waren, vielleicht als Spieler oder einfach auch schon höheren Ämtern. Und da kann man jetzt nicht davon sprechen, dass sie komplett unabhängig sind. Aber das ist ja vielleicht eh klar bei Vereinen. Wenn sie ihre eigene Vergangenheit aufklären wollen, dann geht es ja erst mal nicht komplett unabhängig, wenn kein extra Gremium beauftragt wird.
Das macht man ja auch erst mal nicht für die Öffentlichkeit, sondern erst mal für sich und dann entscheidet man, was man da mit der Öffentlichkeit teilt. Aber das heißt, die Vereine wirken kooperativ, während man bei der Universität Freiburg, das kann man ja auch nachlesen, du hattest schon von den verschiedenen Kommissionen gesprochen, die da sich zusammengesetzt und wieder aufgegeben haben, da kann man, finde ich, in der Medienberichterstattung ganz gut nachverfolgen, wie teilweise, ja ich würde fast sagen, meiner Meinung nach chaotisch es da in den letzten Jahren genau bei dieser Sache lief. Jetzt reden wir ja über ein systemisches Doping. Zumindest wirkt es so von außen jetzt meiner Meinung nach. Und alles kam ja auch so ein bisschen hoch im Zuge des Radsport-Doping-Skandals. Das Team Telekom ist da ganz wichtig und so kam das Ganze ins Rollen. Und wir reden jetzt hier eigentlich über einen sehr, sehr langen Zeitraum. Das heißt, ihr habt jetzt gerade Belege gefunden, dass es Anabolika-Bestellungen gab Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er. Wir wissen, dass zum Beispiel ein Arzt wie Andreas Schmidt beim SC Freiburg bis 2007 tätig war. Also sehr, sehr lange. Jetzt kann man da jetzt nicht gleich eine Relation herstellen. Aber für wie wahrscheinlich hältst du es das denn jetzt deiner Meinung nach, dass sich diese Doping-Vorfälle nicht nur auf diesen Zeitraum in den 80ern beschränken, sondern deinem Gefühl nach, glaubst du, das geht auch mehr in den modernen Fußball hinein, würde ich sagen, ab 90er aufwärts?
Na, was sehr klar ist, dass sozusagen die Doping-Zeiträume an dem Universitätsklinikum, die erstrecken sich über Jahrzehnte. Das ist sozusagen auch belegt. Das ist sozusagen eine Kette, die man nachvollziehen kann. Von damals Klümper, dann gab es den Keul, dann den Schmidt und seinen Kollegen und so. Das war ein richtiges Doping-Zentrum über Jahrzehnte, was sozusagen erstmal wirklich aufgeklärt werden musste, damit sich das verändern kann. Wo es wichtig war, dass da berichtet wird. Ob nun dann immer Fußballer dabei gewesen sind, das kann ich natürlich so jetzt nicht beantworten. Aber was zum Beispiel Freiburg selber sagt, ist, dass auch Schmidt im Universitätsklinikum die Spieler empfangen hat und dort betreut hat. Was dann da genau passiert ist, das kann ich so nicht sagen. Aber ich frage mich trotzdem, ob er da so komplett andere Methoden angewandt hat, als das er bei anderen Sportarten gemacht hat. Im Radsport ist bekannt, dass er dort regelmäßig auch Radsportler empfangen hat, Transfusionen zu geben. Verbotene Bluttransfusionen. Und Spieler, ich sage schon Radfahrer, während der Tour de France extra hingefahren sind an Ruhetagen oder wenn es gerade irgendwie gutes Gelegen war, um da sich extra nochmal eine Transfusion abzuholen. Und beim SC Freiburg ist auch klar, da steht sozusagen auch ein Gutachten, dass sich damals ein anderer Arzt beschwert hat, dass es so viele Transfusionen gibt. Da taucht nicht das Wort Bluttransfusionen oder sowas auf. Aber es gibt viele Zusammenhänge erstmal. Das ist das sozusagen, was ich vorhin auch meinte. Ich glaube, es würde sich total dohnen, die jüngere Vergangenheit des SC Freiburg mal genauer aufzuklären, wie da genau behandelt wurde. Na ja, vielleicht ist erstmal die Beleglage nicht so eindeutig. Wir haben ja damals diese staatsanwaltschaftlichen Ermittlungen, habe ich ja schon gesagt, die waren konkret bezogen auf Klümper. Deswegen gab es Belege. Das Einzige, was es in Freiburg auch gab, waren staatsanwaltschaftliche Ermittlungen, auch gegen Andreas Schmidt nach dem Telekom-Skandal. Aber da scheint nicht so ein Belege aufgetaucht zu sein wie damals bei Klümper. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie man das genau aufklären kann. Journalistisch ist das eh schwer. Eine ganz große Chance liegt darin, mit Zeitzeugen einfach zu sprechen. Wir rufen auch mal unter unseren Texten dazu auf. Wir sind auch gerade im Gespräch mit ehemaligen Spielern aus der Zeit. Das wäre natürlich eine Möglichkeit, dass sich so Leute zu Wort melden. Das ist, glaube ich, auch das größte Potenzial, was es gibt. Aber dass der Verein selber da was macht. Also nun mal als Beispiel Fritz Keller, zum Beispiel der Präsident des SC Freiburg. Der saß schon seit 1994 im Vorstand vom SC Freiburg. Ist noch länger im Verein. Und er hatte schon lange eine Chance, das mal genauer zu erklären. Und was war damals genau passiert ist. Zum Beispiel mit dem Ersatztorwart, der in den 90ern dann da positiv getestet wurde. Was ist denn da genau abgelaufen? Und das wurde ja alles nicht gemacht.
Ja, das kann man, das kann man glaube ich definitiv festhalten. Jetzt hast du vorhin schon erwähnt, dass Dr. Armin Klümper damals einen Guru-Ruf hatte. Du hast es eben verglichen mit dem Ruf, den heute Dr. Müller-Wohlfahrt genießt. Glaubst du daran liegt das auch, dass wir jetzt immer nur über den VfB Stuttgart und den SC Freiburg reden? Weil das ist ja schon auffällig, dass wir jetzt hier es nur mit zwei Südwestdeutschen Vereinen zu tun haben. Und ich würde jetzt mal einfach die These in den Raum stellen. Das ist jetzt nur eine Meinungsäußerung meinerseits. Wenn der VfB Stuttgart mit 600 Anabolikatabletten im Gepäck in seinen Trainingslager fährt, dann würde ich jetzt mal davon ausgehen, dass er nicht der einzige von 18 Vereinen ist, der das macht und auch nicht vielleicht nur zwei von 18 Vereinen. Ist das tatsächlich ein Zufall, dass wir jetzt immer über einen VfB Stuttgart und SC Freiburg sprechen, einfach weil wir diese Belege haben aufgrund der anderen staatsanwaltschaftlichen Ermittlungen? Oder worum funktioniert das?
Ich glaube, das ist ein großer Grund, dass dort aus anderen Motiven heraus Untersuchungen begonnen haben, wodurch die Bezüge klar wurden. Und warum tauchen da jetzt immer nur die Vereine auf? Das lässt sich nicht so einfach beantworten, aber vor anderthalb Jahren, als die erste Welle kam, haben sich auch mehrere Spieler zu Wort gemeldet, dass auch andere Vereine dorthin gegangen sind. Da wurde FC Bayern München konkret genannt, Karlsruhe SC weiß ich noch. Jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr, welcher der dritte Verein war. Da gab es auch andere Bezüge zu anderen Spielern. Die erkennt man auch dadurch, dass Armin Klümper, nachdem er seine Tätigkeit bei den Universitätskliniken aufgegeben hat, er selber auf eigener Finanzierung weitergemacht hat und dort Fußballer um sich gesammelt, die Geld für ihn gesammelt haben, für einen Förderverein. Da waren auch Spieler vom FC Bayern München mit drin. Paul Breitner habe ich noch in Erinnerung. Die werden ja Bezug zu ihm gehabt haben und einen Grund gehabt haben, warum sie um Mengt-Wolten, dass er weiter seine Tätigkeit nachgehen kann. Also die gibt es schon. In Zukunft kommt der Punkt, dass es auch ein regionaler Grund ist, dass die Vereine mal in der Nähe lagen und sich dort ihr Zentrum gesucht haben, sich bangeln zu lassen. Man müsste vielleicht mal ganz andere Zentren aufdecken, wo es bisher einfach keine Ermittlungen gibt. Wohin sich die nördlichen Vereine oder noch mehr westlichen Vereine hinorientiert haben. Die werden nicht alle dahingereist sein. Auch bei Müller-Wolfhardt ist es ja so, dass zwar ganz viele einzelne Spieler, extrem viele einzelne Spieler immer mal wieder zu ihm hinreisen, aber oft nach Verletzungen. Aber so die grundsätzliche sportmedizinische Versorgung passiert ja woanders. Bei den Vereinen haben sie ihre eigenen Stützpunkte. Das war ja damals nicht anders.
Es gibt das weit verbreitete Vorurteil, würde ich es nennen. Doping im Fußball würde nichts bringen. Das haben wir im Tribünengespräch, finde ich, damals sehr ausführlich besprochen. Und die Punkte genannt, an denen man sagen kann, es kann schon etwas bringen. Und es gibt ja auch wirklich eine ganze Handvoll von Belegen für Doping im Fußball. Also es ist eine Illusion zu glauben, der Fußball wäre ein dopingfreier Sport. Jetzt fällt aber dem neutralen Beobachter wie mir schon auf, dass die wesentlichen Akteure, die Diskussionen hier vorantreiben und die auch neue Erkenntnisse ans Licht drücken, eben oft tatsächlich auf journalistischer Seite sitzen. Und da seid ja auch gerade ihr mit eurer Seite fußballdoping.de ganz vorne mit dabei. Kannst du mal kurz für die Hörer beschreiben, wie ihr da vorgeht? Du hast schon gesagt, die wichtigste Quelle sind Zeitzeugen.
Genau, dazu nochmal konkret. Was wir sozusagen machen, ist, dass wir, was wir probieren, es fällt uns auf die Zeit, eine Liste einfach uns aufgeschrieben haben von ehemaligen Akteuren, mit denen wir gerne ins Gespräch kommen würden. Und wir versuchen, mit denen um den Kontakt zu treten, wenn es unsere Zeit immer laupt. Das kann sein über einen handschriftlich geschriebenen Brief, weil der vielleicht Leute ganz anders erreicht, als eine E-Mail, die man schnell wegklickt. Oder einfach durch direkte Telefonate. Wir haben das große Problem, dass wir oft sozusagen einen kalten Kontakt starten. Das heißt, die Person kennt uns nicht, wir wurden nicht empfohlen von Bekannten oder so. Wir müssen erst mal mit uns vorstellen und warm werden und Vertrauen gewinnen. Das ist eine ganz große Hürde dabei. Aber das ist sozusagen das eine, wo ich, wie gesagt, auch die großen Chancen drin sehe. Mir sind auch schon witzige Sachen passiert, dass ich mit Spielern einen langen handschriftlichen Brief geschrieben habe. Der, warte, wie sage ich das? Ich wollte den Namen jetzt nicht sagen. Ich habe sozusagen an jemanden, der jetzt ein Weingut betreiben soll, einen langen Brief geschrieben, habe auch das Wein gefunden mit demselben Namen und habe dann aber nur zwei Seiten geschrieben, um eine E-Mail zu bekommen. Ja, der Name ist richtig, aber ich habe nur in der Zehung Fußball gespielt. Danke für die Mühe, das ist alles sehr spannend, aber ich bin das nicht. Dann habe ich jetzt eigentlich nur Wein bei dem bestellt, aber keine Informationen bekommen. Ich muss jetzt nochmal einen neuen Zugang finden, aber da sind wir aktiv dabei. Die härteren Sachen sind natürlich nochmal Dokumente und da muss man genauer schauen, wo irgendwie Dokumente möglich sind. Das kann durch staatsanwaltschaftliche Ermittlungen sein, aber da ist glaube ich schon relativ viel abgegrast. Oder es kann auch zu Akteuren sein, die da drin waren, also Ärzte, Masseure, anderen Betreuer und so, die vielleicht auch nochmal Dokumente vor sich liegen haben. Wenn man die sieht, kann man auch nochmal ganz andere Sachen machen. Genau, das sind eigentlich die Hauptwege. Aber es ist wirklich Schritt für Schritt, sonst hätten wir auch schon mehr gemacht.
Das glaube ich. Ich denke, das ist auch schon deutlich geworden, warum es schwierig ist. Und wir haben ja jetzt auch schon oft genug betont, dass es eher ein Zufall ist, dass wir jetzt in diesem einen Fall vom VfB Stuttgart und SC Freiburg bei einigen beteiligten Leuten viele Belege haben, die jetzt im Nachhinein nochmal eine zweite Bedeutung quasi bekommen, dadurch, dass sie archiviert wurden. Jetzt gibt es ja nicht nur die journalistische Seite. Ihr macht das über das Korrektiv. Das ist ein investigatives Rechercheverbund, würde ich sagen, der unterstützt werden kann von...
Genau. Wir sind ganz kurz zusammengefasst. Wir sind gemeinnützig. Das unterscheidet uns zu den klassischen Medien in Deutschland. Wir werden über Spenden finanziert. Der größte Teil von Fördern, mit denen man für 10 Euro im Monat sozusagen unsere Arbeit unterstützen kann. Wir haben den Vorteil, dass wir lange an Geschichten sitzen können. Wir arbeiten immer bei der Verbreitung mit traditionellen Medien zusammen, die dann kostenlos unsere Geschichten bekommen. Die Geschichte wurde jetzt auf Zeit Online gespiegelt, war doch lange aufmacher gestern Abend. Dafür haben wir uns kein Geld gegeben, nur einen Hinweis geschrieben, wer wir sind und wie wir finanziert werden. So funktioniert das Modell.
Genau, und ihr seid eben nicht gewinnorientiert und dadurch, glaube ich, auch unabhängiger in eurer Arbeit. Das ist quasi der Hintergrund zum Korrektiv und zu fußballdoping.de. Jetzt gibt es hier aber auch noch die nationale Anti-Doping-Agentur, über die ich gleich noch mal in einem anderen Zusammenhang mit dir sprechen wollen würde. Welche Rolle spielt die denn bei solchen Ermittlungen? Die hat wahrscheinlich nicht die Kapazitäten, nachträgliche Investigativrecherche zu machen. Das kann wahrscheinlich so eine Agentur nicht leisten.
Ja, also dafür fehlt der NADA schlichtweg auch das Geld. Und ich würde das auch falsch sehen, wenn jetzt die NADA aktiv in den 70er, 80er Jahren anfängt zu wühlen. Ich glaube, für die ist wichtig, dass sie sich positionieren als Ansprechpartner, Vertrauenswürdiger auch für mögliche Missleblower. Das können auch Leute aus der Zeit sein, damit Strukturen aufgedeckt werden, die vielleicht gegenwärtig auch noch existieren. Das ist wichtig, dass sie da in dem Feld sich bewegen, aber nicht jetzt aktiv alle Details zu nahe ins Aufklären. Das ist wichtiger, dass sie das in der Gegenwart tun, durch besonders Kontrollen, aber auch durch die amerikanische Anti-Doping-Agentur, die bei Lance Armstrong ganz wichtig war, in dem möglichst vielen Leuten auch reden, und dann als vertrauenswürdig wahrgenommen werden. Was ein großes Problem ist für die Anti-Doping-Agenturen jetzt durch die letzten Monate, weil gerade in dem Bereich viele Datenschutzprobleme passiert sind. Es gab bei diesen großen Hack rund um die Olympischen Spiele jetzt, wo aus diesem internen System, Adams nennt sich das, personenbezogene Daten, medizinische Daten veröffentlicht wurden von russischen Hackern. Da sehen wir, welche Ausnahmegenehmigungen haben sich Sportler schreiben lassen für irgendwelche Medikamente, die eigentlich verboten sind, die aber aus irgendwelchen gesundheitlichen Gründen doch genommen werden mussten. Und so relativ persönliche Sachen. Dadurch hat, glaube ich, Instagram der ganze Anti-Doping-Bereich von Behördenseite aus auch nochmal ein großes Problem jetzt, womit sie gerade zu kämpfen haben. Dass sie da wieder Vertrauen gewinnen, auch den Sportlern gegenüber.
Ja, das war tatsächlich ein herber Rückschlag im Image der Anti-Doping-Agenturen. Dabei sollte eigentlich jeder Sportwenderin interessiert sein, dass die möglichst unabhängig und möglichst umfassend arbeiten können. Denn ich glaube, die Mehrheit aller Sportfans würde sich schon darauf verständigen, dass wir es gerne ohne Doping im Sport hätten. Jetzt hast du schon ein entscheidendes Wort fallen lassen, nämlich die Finanzierung der NADA. Und wir haben auch schon über begrenzte Kapazitäten gesprochen. Und das ist ein zweites Thema, was in dieser Woche aufkam. Es wurde bekannt, dass adidas, der Konzern, aus der Finanzierung der NADA aussteigt. Bisher hat man 300.000 Euro zugeschossen. Und auch dazu habe ich jetzt eine Reihe Fragen an dich erst mal. Wie kommt denn das eigentlich zustande, dass ein Unternehmen, die NADA unterstützt? War das von Anfang an so ausgelegt? Ich hatte die NADA, ehrlich gesagt, immer als eine Verbandsinstitution abgespeichert.
Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie das bei der Gründung war. Aber die letzten Jahre war es auf jeden Fall so, dass es quasi eine Mischfinanzierung war. Der größte Teil kommt sozusagen bei Steuergeräten zustande von Bund und Ländern. Und dann gibt es aber auch Zuwendungen über andere Stiftungen, über die Wirtschaft. Das ist ja jetzt ein aktueller Aspekt. Und ich überlege gerade, habe ich noch was anderes vergessen. Bund, Länder, Wirtschaft, Stiftungen. Ich glaube, vielleicht gibt es auch irgendwelche Privatspenden, die dürften aber nur kein Beitrag sein. Das ist schon immer so eine vielfältige Finanzierung gewesen. Aber wo du komplett recht hast, ist, insgesamt kann man die NADA als Behörde betrachten, weil so z.B. die Mehrheit der Finanzierung durch öffentliche Gelder zustande kommt. Und der Anteil wird sehr wahrscheinlich auch weiter größer werden. Und das ist auch der Kernteil der Diskussionen in den letzten Jahren gewesen, wie viel Bund und Länder dazu geben. Da gab es natürlich verschiedene Interessen, gerade von Länderseite aus, dass die Beteiligung unterschiedlich hoch sein sollte. Es ist aber auch spannend, das zu wissen, um als Hinterkopf zu haben, dass mehrheitlich ein öffentlicher Hand ist aus journalistischer Sicht, weil die NADA im doping-Bereich einer der wenigen Behörden ist, die dadurch auskunftspflichtig ist. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht zu tief drüber reden, wenn wir auch geistig viel Zeit haben, aber das finde ich spannend, weil sonst hat man eher das Problem beim DFB und natürlich bei allen Vereinen, das ist alles Geld. Die einzigen Ankünftungsbereiche, wo man auch noch mal Sachen fragen kann, die beantwortet werden müssen durch die Auskunftspflicht, sind dann halt so Sachen wie die Geldgeber vom Bundesministerium, wovon viel Geld kommt, aber auch bei der NADA selbst. Wenn man da kluge Fragen hat, dann kann man die auch stellen und die müssen zum großen Teil auch beantwortet werden.
Im letzten Jahr hatte die NADA ein Etat von neun Millionen Euro. Mehr als ein Drittel davon kam vom Bund. Das hast du ja die Finanzierung gerade schon aufgedröselt.
Ich glaube sogar noch mehr, weil der Bund ist so komisch geteilt. Es gibt dann um je vom Bund so ein Forschungsbudget und nochmal so ein allgemeines Budget. Was hast du gerade gesagt? Mehr als ein Drittel?
Mehr als ein Drittel, genau. Es kommt dann von den Bundesländern auch nochmal knapp 150.000 Euro, vor allem für Präventionsprojekte, habe ich jetzt gelesen. Also es ist eine Mischfinanzierung. Auf jeden Fall viel Geld aus öffentlicher Hand. Wir haben es aber eben auch schon angedeutet. Es kommt eben auch aus der Wirtschaft. Da war die Telekom früher mal involviert, die Deutsche Bank. Und jetzt eben Adidas. Und ich würde sagen, die 300.000, die da fehlen, die reißen da schon eine Lücke. Adidas hat, soweit ich es gesehen habe, dafür keine Begründung geliefert für diesen Rückzug.
Genau. Also das haben sie nicht. Es ist auch nicht so, dass Adidas bekannt gegeben hat, sondern eine Geschäftsführer der NADA, Herr Mozifer, hat das sozusagen, ich glaube immer die Bild-Zeitung, dann sozusagen die Öffentlichkeit gespint, dass das Geld fehlt. Und Adidas hat versucht, da stillschweigend auszusteigen. Ich finde, hier ist jetzt gerade ein Tontest. Das geht hoffentlich noch mit der Grund. Sonst musst du mir Bescheid sagen. Also, Adidas, genau. Also das, was ich spannend finde daran ist, dass die Frage, ob nicht der Imageverlust für Adidas jetzt größer ist, wenn sie da aussteigen, als wenn sie da einfach weiter ein bisschen Geld geben. Jetzt wurde dadurch einmal eine Diskussion eröffnet. Kann auch sein, dass sie ab heute Nachmittag schon wieder vorbei ist. Aber da müssen sie sich jetzt erstmal zurecht schlagen. Was Adidas immer selber sagt ist, sie hätten ja in ihren Klauseln mit den Adidas-Sportlern diesen Untervertrag stehen. Wenn es einen Doping-Test gibt, dann kann der Vertrag gekündigt werden. Das finde ich aber eine lächerliche Omutation, dem Zornbank, weil Doping-Tests, also positiver Tests, kann ja nur zustande kommen, wenn eine gute Anti-Doping-Arbeit geleistet werden kann.
Das wäre genau das Argument, was ich auch hätte bringen wollen. Und gleichzeitig ist es sehr erstaunlich, wenn man die Summen, die ein Konzern wie Adidas ausgibt, sonst im Sponsoring einfach mal diesen 300.000 Euro gegenüber setzt. Da hast du einen Deal mit Manchester United, der für kolportierte 100 Millionen Euro geschlossen wurde. Und, und, und, und, und dann sind 300.000 wirklich ein kleiner Betrag. Das heißt, ich denke, man kann schon sagen, das zeigt, dass der Anti-Doping-Kampf, also aus der Wirtschaft erfährt er jetzt keine Unterstützung, keine Unterstützung mehr. Adidas war der letzte Sponsor aus der Wirtschaft.
Genau.
Gleichzeitig haben wir es hier mit einem Imageproblem generell zu tun, zum Teil ausgemacht, muss man sagen. Also diese Daten, diese Datenleaks, die waren für alle Beteiligten nicht angenehm und nicht schön. So etwas sollte nicht passieren. Und gleichzeitig haben wir aber auch, das haben wir auch im Tribüngespräch damals besprochen, die Realität, dass die Anti-Doping-Agenturen immer einen Schritt hinterher sind. Sie müssen immer neue Tests entwickeln für neue Medikamente. Es ist ein Hase-Igel-Spiel. Und da wäre natürlich eine breite Finanzierung besser als eine dünne Finanzierung.
Genau, also vielleicht kann man noch eine Sache zur Finanzierung ergänzen. Was wir damals auch besprochen haben, ist, dass im Fußball die Finanzierung ein bisschen anders abläuft. Das kommt sozusagen nicht aus dem Jahresbudget heraus, sondern der DFB gibt ja direkt Geld an die NADA für die Kontrollen. Du hast ja gerade schon diesen Vergleich gezogen, wie viel Geld Adi das macht und dass 300.000 dann nicht viel waren. Das Gleiche kann man beim DFB auch sagen mit seinen Milliarden umsetzend. Der DFB gibt, jetzt habe ich hier die aktuellen Zahlen nicht vor Augen, aber es war knapp eine Million, der NADA für die Doping-Kontrollen. Und an dieser Summe muss sozusagen die NADA ausrechnen, wie viele Kontrollen möglich sind. Das ist genau dasselbe Spielchen. Der DFB könnte sich jetzt sicher erlauben, wie all das einfach rauszugehen, dann würde es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen länger diskutiert werden. Aber man trotzdem kann festhalten, dass das nicht viel Geld ist. Also wenn sie es wirklich richtig wichtig finden würden, dass es möglichst wenig Chancen gibt zu dopen, dann müssten sie da deutlich mehr Geld geben.
Du beschäftigst dich jetzt schon sehr lange mit Doping im Fußball und Doping auch generell. Du bist ja auch im Radspaß sehr viel journalistisch aktiv gewesen, eben zusammen mit Daniel Drepper und dem Korrektiv. Was würdest du jetzt sagen? Jetzt haben wir auf der einen Seite euren Artikel von Dienstagabend, in dem wir neue Belege für Doping in der Vergangenheit haben. Und wir haben die andere Seite, eine Entwicklung aus der Gegenwart, wo die nationale Anti-Doping-Agentur die letzte Unterstützung aus der Wirtschaft verliert. Wo würdest du sagen, Doping, jetzt auch nicht nur für den Fußball gesprochen, im Jahr 2016, wie ist da die Situation? Ich habe den Eindruck, von außen betrachtet ehrlich gesagt, der Anti-Doping-Kampf ist eher ein Feigenblatt ganz oft. Und so wirklich ernsthaft wird er von eigentlich allen Beteiligten nicht verfolgt.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass es gerade ein dramatischer Kampf ist, mit einer Situation, was in der Zukunft möglich ist, weil die großen Institutionen sich massiv positionieren müssen, warum sie noch die sind, denen man vertrauen sollte. Das gilt ja besonders für die Welt Anti-Doping-Agentur. Ich muss auch fairerweise sagen, dieses System ADAMS ist ein System der Welt Anti-Doping-Agentur, nicht der deutschen. Das betrifft aber natürlich alle Agenturen. Was ich aber als große Chance sehe, ist, das Gefühl habe ich gerade auch im letzten Gespräch mit der NADA gehabt, dass sie merken, das wird jetzt auch noch mal ein Existenzkampf und vielleicht auch offensiver anfangen, über die eigene Arbeit zu sprechen, auch mit Journalisten und anderen Menschen. Bisher hatte ich das Gefühl, gerade im deutschen Bereich, dass immer sozusagen auch eine Angst da war, wenn sie sich jetzt zu offensiv in bestimmte Richtungen äußern, dann verschwindet vielleicht wieder einer der Geldgeber. Jetzt haben wir schon mal die Wirtschaft raus. Da kann man jetzt sozusagen keine Interessen mehr gefährden. Vielleicht wird es jetzt alles ein bisschen unter den Finger, beziehungsweise vertrauen sich auch die Leute in den Ad-Doping-Behörden noch deutlicher Sachen zu sagen und sich auch Daten auszutauschen, mit Daten, nicht persönliche Daten, aber grundsätzlicher Daten zu kontrollen und so weiter mit journalistischen Organisationen und anderen, die da irgendwie unterwegs sind. Und klar kann es nicht so sein, dass man da irgendwie Hand in Hand arbeitet. Dafür muss man sozusagen von da nach unabhängig bleiben. Aber ich glaube, da steckt auch eine Menge Kraft drin. Die ist jetzt zu nutzen gilt einfach in einem richtigen Moment. Aber ich kann das auch nicht voraussehen, wie sich das alles ändern wird. Es kann zum Beispiel sein, dass bald ein neues System genutzt werden muss, dass dieses Adam-System wegfällt nach dem massiven Datenlag. Dann müssen sich plötzlich alle Sportler weltweit ein neues System eintragen. Das wäre eine riesen Umstellung. Kann ich auch nur in die Glasskuhl versuchen zu schauen.
Eines ist klar, Jonathan, du wirst dranbleiben. Das war Jonathan Sachse vom Rechercheverbund korrektiv.org, der zusammen mit Daniel Drepper die Seite fußballdoping.de betreibt. Und Jonathan, obwohl du unterwegs bist, du bist hier bereit erklärt. Deswegen verzeihen wir es dir auch gerne, wenn du nicht alle Organigramme vor Augen hattest. Vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst, Jonathan.
Sehr gerne.
Man kann dir auf Twitter folgen unter et.jsachse, wenn ich es richtig habe. Richtig. Und Daniel unter et.danieldrepper. Das war der Rasen von Kurzpass. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, liebe Zuhörer.